a majority of voters say they feel
confident about the nation's economy our
CBS News exit poll found about
two-thirds of voters think the economy
is excellent or good that's the highest
number in a midterm election since 1998
but forty nine percent also said their
family's financial position is about the
same as it was two years ago Ariel
Investments president and CBS News
financial contributor Mellody Hobson is
here to explain that to us melody what
do you make of that discrepancy I think
part of the issue is the fact that wages
have been stagnant mostly they are now
going up we're seeing it in a brisk pace
and so people are now seeing bigger
paychecks I think the other thing was
the tax cut that was so big at the time
largely affected corporate America as
opposed to individuals so people did not
see that money in their paychecks didn't
pass on to them correctly what do you
think the market's reaction will be to
divided government that we now have so
this is interesting I actually just went
back to history to look at this I looked
at midterm elections since the late
1940s there have been 18 of them one
year after every single midterm the
stock market was up every single one no
we have that saying in the mutual fund
industry past performance is not a
guarantee of future results but that is
the data and interestingly the better
performing periods are periods were the
houses were split in terms of leadership
so what do you expect when the markets
open this morning coming up well we
probably will see a strong open the Dow
futures are pointing towards a strong
open up 200 points or so as when I last
loved but one day is a blip in the
market it's really the longer-term story
that matters and I love that saying that
Warren Buffett has markets are stronger
than governments we're at the end of the
day that's what will you know rule the
day I always turn to the Oracle of Omaha
for we're entering our tenth year of an
economic recovery is there anything you
see on the horizon that worries you
about a downturn there's not a lot to
get nervous about I mean there it's a
stunning time economically when you look
at the jobs numbers which will continue
to be strong when you look at the wage
inflation which has to be managed and
the Fed is looking at that inflation
overall but the fact that people are
doing better and making more money
that is a really good story we virtually
have full employment in the United
States it's just not something we've
seen in a long time when you talk to
individual companies and the CEOs which
I do a lot they're saying that their
businesses are solid and so there's
nothing there no giant red flags I think
the thing we have to worry about the
traits skirmish I'll call it a war
what's going on there and will the
Democrats play into that as well China
in particular and melody and
infrastructure if by some grace of God
there's compromise in Washington between
the Democrats and President Trump and an
infrastructure plan which America needs
right and could desperately the market
and businesses would love that too they
would love it but I think it's a super
long shot because of the deficit the
deficit grew so much because of the tax
cut I think that is going to be a really
hard sell even though these bridges and
roads desperately need it the
construction industry would benefit
tremendously and that would ultimately
again affect everyday people but I think
it's gonna be hard to get it done all
right now do you have some thanks so
much for being with us